dude people are hungry for this movie i
remember the excitement around your
first comic con how does this experience
compare
i think it doesn't really compare
because we've come through so much in
the last several years you know what i
mean things that none of us could see so
this is the first time any of us have
been back in hall h
in years
not just because of covid but because we
haven't made another black panther but
we haven't been able to do communal
things the way that we used to so being
able to come back here and kind of exist
in the old days and see something
a new
was powerful
usually hall h is very very electric but
there was something that was so
still
and beautiful about it you know there
was a there was
a powerful excited calm
at times
that you could feel and they were like
you said
hungry it was highly emotional up there
how does
the memory and legacy of chadwick bind
you all together
the legacy of chadwick binds us together
because chadwick and the rest of us as a
collective created something really
special with number one
and when he transitioned
we were left with the baton
in this relay to carry the narrative
forward to wherever we're gonna take it
you know and we feel exceptionally
just full of gratitude to be able to do
that
that's how we honor him is to carry the
story forward we honor him by constantly
being
just diligent with our integrity around
our work because he was
and you know it's something special and
i just can't wait for people to get to
see what wakanda forever really means
it's beautiful man thank you for your
time appreciate you